hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime outboard and the mha
ending is shaping up to be an absolute
scorcher the arch villain all for one is
at his strongest Point ever he has
attained godly power and he is in his
prime but his Quirk is also killing him
will all for one read shikaraki and
implant his Quirk factor into him what
if he implants his Quirk factor into
Deku instead what if all for one's plan
all along was to use Deku as his
ultimate vessel a vessel that possesses
both all for one and one for all let's
get into it you guys know the drill if
you enjoy our mha video you want to see
more in the future leave a quick like
and comment right now quick thank you to
the sponsor of this video the one the
only raid Shadow Legends I feel like
everyone's heard of raid by now but what
is raid the r stands for regular up
updates if you've tried raid before but
you haven't gone back in a while hop on
again because they've got tons of
updates dropping every month the a
stands for arena where you can test your
strength against other players and prove
the dominance of your unique Champions
the I stands for immensely satisfying
battle system which gives you intense
PVE and PVP content including tactical
upgrade systems epic strategic gameplay
and much more finally the d stands for
do it now click that link in the
description and find out for yourself
why Everyone is always talking about
raid Shadow Legends and guess what
raid's fourth anniversary is finally
here and after four years they've gone
absolutely crazy with the giveaways I'm
talking dedicated offers free gifts
promo codes and a brand new Fusion event
where you can get your hands on an
anniversary themed legendary champion
right now you can use the promo code
four years raid to get some extra stuff
for Amazon Prime members who just got
gambo keep an eye out for the next drop
with some powerful Savage gear it's
available from March 2nd until March
30th new players use my link or scan the
QR code right here and get a free
starter pack with this cool in-game loot
try it out for yourself click the link
in the description or click the QR code
right now finally this video will
contain mha manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned in the previous chapter we saw
that toga was unable to replicate the
quirks of anyone that she doesn't truly
love so she was unable to use the
corrects of shigarakidavi and all for
one even after successfully cloning them
using twice as Quirk we also witnessed a
huge twist as the absolute monster
gigantomakia appeared on the goonga
battlefield as we know Makia is
incredibly loyal to his master all for
one so at that point it looked like it
was all over for the heroes they were
about to be destroyed by Makia and all
for one was going to use that
opportunity to reach shigaraki however
instead of attacking all for one's
enemies gigantomakia did something
shocking he attacked all for one himself
that's because Shin so had managed to
brainwash machia into thinking that he
shinso was his master all for one
leading machia to conclude that he had
to obey all of shinso's commands the
success of this strategy could also have
something to do with the fact that all
for one now looks completely different
from what he looked like before and then
he probably sounds a lot different too
since his body has been rewound to when
he was much younger around the age of a
teenager the latest chapter begins with
the full breakdown and explanation of
how the massive gigantamakia twist came
into being it all started at the jakku
hospital ruins after news spread about
Shoto defeating Dobby news that we now
know ended up being premature there at
the ruins of jakku Hospital a special
containment structure had been created
in order to keep machia trapped inside
but a bunch of villains decided that
they would break him out multiple Heroes
and hero students were guarding machia
at that location and once the villains
showed up a full-fledged battle
commenced at first most of the NPC
villains are just dealt with by zuzo
honanuki from class 1B who used his
softening Quirk to trap a bunch of them
in what is essentially quicksand but
juzo's Quirk cannot help against that
villain with a creepy tube mask who was
responsible for killing midnight that
villain is able to float through the air
and he is also able to make several
other villains float along with him
which renders juuzou's ground-based
Quirk useless what's more this tube face
villain and his comrades came prepared
they are here specifically because they
want to break Makia out of his
confinement and they brought a device
that can broadcast over one's voice loud
enough for Makia to hear it so it's a
similar situation to spinner trying to
use an audio device to awaken kurogire
and even though Makia is sealed away
inside a concrete treat structure one of
his many quirks gives him an extremely
sensitive sense of hearing like the
hearing of a dog the fact that Makia
possesses this Quirk practically
guarantees that he will hear the
recording device Mount lady is there
along with a bunch of hero students
including juzo and also minata Mina
kirishima and yui kodai from class 1B
Mount lady knows exactly how dangerous
Makia is and she immediately rushes at
the villains in an attempt to prevent
them from accomplishing their mission
yui from class 1B uses her Quirk size to
turn a normal sized wrench into a
gigantic warhammer-sized weapon for
Mount lady to wield she then starts
using the giant wrench to try to swat
the villains out of the sky by the way
if you're interested in yui's Quirk size
and the other class 1B quirks I am
currently working on a video that will
explain all of them in detail and
include all the updates and upgrades as
of the final Arc of the story if that's
a video you'd like to check out when it
comes out please subscribe right now and
click the notification Bell to turn on
all notifications that is the only way
to make sure that YouTube will actually
inform you when the video is live
unfortunately for Mount Lady it's
already too late the villain's plan has
already succeeded because Makia heard
what he needed to hear and he suddenly
bursts out of his confinement as the
entire building that he had been
contained in collapses into dust it's
one thing to try to sedate and confine
Makia when he is relatively calm but
when he hears his master calling him his
strength multiplies many times over and
he becomes an explosive overpowered
monster that simply cannot be contained
the heroes and hero students are now in
major major trouble I'm sure I don't
need to explain to any of you guys who
are watching this video right now just
how insanely strong Makia is and the
last time that he was on the loose many
civilians and heroes died including of
course midnight the heroes are
completely finished now unless they have
another final trick up their sleeve and
as kirishima reveals luckily they do
back when this latest war first started
the heroes were able to secretly warp
shinso to this location and he has been
hiding ever since so the villains aren't
even aware that he is there well most of
the villains aren't because when
kirishima runs to the spot where Shinzo
was hiding he finds that that sludge
villain from chapter 1 trying to take
over shinsel's body when the villains
arrived the sludge villain decided to go
into hiding and wait it out because he's
a coward but when he accidentally
stumbled upon shinzo's hiding spot he
decided to try to take over his body
thankfully kirishima is having none of
it and he immediately engages the sludge
villain in battle meanwhile Makia
completely overpowers Mountain 80 very
quickly and he demands to know where his
master is and just as Makia is about to
finish off Mount lady with his giant
claws Mina steps in and unleashes a
brand new level of power pushing her
acid Quirk to its maximum output to
straight up plus Ultra she unleashes an
attack called acid man Alma and this
attack actually manages to break down
and Destroy Machias Claws Mount blady is
shocked that Mina was able to produce
such a strong substance with her Quirk
but Mina doesn't even wait around to
brag about her Newfound strength Mina
has been feeling terrible about not
being stronger earlier and not being
able to prevent the people she cared
about from getting hurt including of
course midnight so she started taking
inspiration from the training methods of
Shoto and bakugou and as a result she
has taken her Quirk and her strength to
the next level she is sick and tired of
failing to protect the ones she cares
about and so her next move is to rush
over to where kirishima is fighting the
sludge villain she then excretes some of
her acid into the sludge and the acid
begins to immediately mix around inside
the villain's body the sludge villain
knows that this is very bad news and he
tries to run away and while he is
panicking and attempting to escape
shinso manages to trick him into
responding to him as soon as that
happens shinso is able to control and
subdue him with shinso now safe and free
to do as he pleases that trick that the
heroes had up their sleeve is finally
revealed shinso uses that special rope
cloth that izawa taught him how to use
in order to get up to makia's head and
he then uses his Persona chords to call
out to machia in the voice of all for
one himself Shinto was able to use
recordings of all for one's voice from
Tartarus to copy his voice with Persona
chords and that is enough to trick
machia machia responds to the sound of
all for one's voice and he is placed
under Shinto's control as a result of
his brainwashing Quirk after that
shinsel orders Makia to swat down
everyone who is floating in the air
Machi obeys and proceeds to take down
the floating villains and the heroes win
the battle the villains fail in their
mission to retrieve Makia and they are
then restrained and detained by the
heroes this explains why Makia was
released from captivity in the first
place and how he came under shinzo's
control now we all knew that Shinto was
able to trick Makia using a combination
of persona chords and his Quirk but at
first I thought the heroes might have
intentionally released Makia in order to
get him under their control and gain an
upper hand over the villains in my video
on the previous chapter I said that this
was a massive risk yes Makia is a huge
asset for the heroes and yes the heroes
are extremely desperate at this point in
time but releasing him could also spell
Doom for all of Japan if all for one is
able to regain control we know now that
the heroes didn't actually release him
on purpose taking that risk was not
their idea but once he was already
released thanks to the efforts of the
villains the Heroes made the best of the
situation thanks to shinsel right after
all this happens Mount lady receives a
call which informs her that all for one
has managed to rewind himself and is now
once again in his prime this leads the
heroes to make the difficult decision to
bring Makia to gunga in the hopes that
they could keep him under control long
enough to defeat All For One the chapter
ends back in the present moment as the
Colossal battle against all for one rage
is an absolutely epic fashion Dark
Shadow Mount lady gigantomakia and all
the other heroes are attacking all for
one in what looks more like some sort of
Mosaic from Greek mythology than a manga
panel and in fact this panel is almost
certainly inspired by popular depictions
of the titanomakia the war between the
Olympian gods and the Titans in Greek
mythology both gigantomakia's name and
the name Tartarus are direct references
to this mythological conflict so I'm not
surprised that horikoshi is bringing out
the Greek mythology references yet again
we also see what looks to be two
helicopters hovering above the
battlefield then we see all for one's
face looking absolutely epic with his
eyes completely white he truly looks
like some sort of dark God of
destruction and that is how this chapter
ends okay those last panels were crazy
and exciting but what's the deal with
those random helicopters was this the
media filming the battle are these
villains who are coming to help over one
and transport him to shigaraki we know
that the villains are likely the reason
why the civilian evacuees from the UA
grounds never made it to their
evacuation checkpoint so I wonder if
these helicopters could be related to
that part of all for one's plan were
they may be sent by those spies who had
infiltrated the UA I don't mean ayama
and his family but the other ones
definitely let me know what you think
about the helicopters down in the
comments also Mina and kirishima had a
short but heartwarming moment in this
chapter that we really have to talk
about during the battle Mina was
extremely tempted to seek revenge
against those villains who are directly
responsible for killing midnight
especially the tube face villain but she
takes inspiration from Shoji Shoji was
bullied and mistreated his entire life
just because he looked different and yet
he refused to be consumed by ideas of
Revenge instead he chose to focus on
becoming a better person and a better
hero this is exactly what Mina intends
to do and even though she shows
impressive self-control and restraint
and even though she does a lot to help
in the battle when the battle ends Mina
feels like once again she wasn't useful
because Shinto was the one who saved the
day and she then collapses from
dehydration after overusing her work but
as she falls kirishima grabs her and
holds her in his arms kirishima tells
Mina that she was never useless and that
she's always been his hero and if you
know anything about their backstory and
how much Mina inspired kirishima then
you know that this panel hits different
man I ship these two so hard horn
buddies forever okay now back to the big
boss all for one we know that even
though he is now in his prime and
probably stronger than he ever was
before his Quirk is also currently
killing him because he chose to rewind
his body to the point that it will
eventually be rewired found right out of
existence and yet even though he is
doomed to disappear soon horikoshi is
still hinting that this guy is
incredibly powerful and he still isn't
done yet I think his eyes turning Pure
White is a hint that something big is
about to happen he still has one last
great power move in him and I think that
he will reach shigaraki and Deku before
he dies but what happens then will all
for one succeed in implanting his Quirk
factor into shigaraki and could this
Kill shigaraki from the inside as all
for one takes over or would shigaraki
just kill all for one instead and become
even stronger than before and while it
would be interesting to see the internal
conflict between shigarak in all for
one's original Quirk Factor we've kind
of already seen the internal conflict
between these guys I think that an even
more interesting scenario would be fall
for one tried to implant his Quirk
factor into Deku instead since Deku is a
quirkland us user of one for all meaning
that he already possesses one for all
and his body isn't going to be
prematurely destroyed because of it
taking over deku's body would be ideal
for all for one not only will he then
possess The all-for-one Quirk Factor but
he would also possess the one for all
Quirk factor that he has been trying to
steal for like a hundred years and on
top of that he would have a fresh new
vessel at his disposal not gonna lie the
inner conflict between Deku and the
vestiges of one for all and all for one
and The all-for-one Quirk Factor would
be absolutely incredible to see there is
just so much history there and I wonder
what this potential turn of events could
do to Deku could over one actually take
control of deku's body and use one for
all for the first time could deku's
personality and mental stability
deteriorate as a result of this internal
struggle could the raw power of both one
for all and all for one overwhelm deku's
body and lead to his ultimate
destruction if I'm being honest I'm now
kinda hoping that all for one does try
to take over Deku instead of shigaraki
because before the story ends I really
want to see what would happen if both
the old for one Quirk factor and the one
for all Quirk Factor ended up inside the
same body what do you guys think will
happen to Deku if all for one implants
The all-for-one Quirk Factor inside of
him let me know down below if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more in the future please leave a like
right now it means a lot and if you are
among the over 50 of people who watch
our videos but haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a big favor and make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification Bell to turn on
all notifications subscribing on YouTube
is completely free but it helps me out a
lot you can also hit me up on Twitter
and Instagram at anime uproar thanks
again to raid Shadow Legends for
sponsoring this video check them out
Link in the description as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see ya Space Cowboys